no I never met this consultum she's  something right [ __ ]  Eloise Mac now she's probably with no  crown Eloise my turn  are you gonna be kidding me  what happened to you after I left drank  a lot of beer  experimental with a serious prawn  cocktail crisps have it I'm moving to  France so this is a goodbye toast now my  train leaves at 6:45  you're right ballbuster Charton shat of  air hundreds of feet above the ground  that caveman  I never stopped thinking about what was  my unforgivable sin I'm sorry I  neglected you I'm sorry I took you for  granted  so nothing it miss  Lito sittest I'm gonna find out Russell  drugs and underneath that city son I'm  gonna find my love color  hey aah oh God  Oh you okay Oh kidding I want to ask you  something all right I want you to answer  me truthfully no jokes you're not doing  this to me nothing now I really do have  to go Oh James come don't know that way  but sometimes waiting snored enough but  you favors the bold love